اذكر مره اخرى اذا باخر التطورات
الميدانيه في القطاع حيث قال مراسل
الجزيره ان غارات اسرائيليه كثيفه من
الطائرات الحربيه استهدفت شرق خان يونس
جنوبي قطاع غزه وفي مخيم جباليا ايضا ما
زالت الاشتباكات العنيفه تدور بين
المقاومه وقوات الاحتلال في منطقه تل
الزعتر بينما نشرت كتائب القسام صورا
لمعارك مع جيش الاحتلال في مدينه غزه وفي
خانيونس جنوبي القطاع وقالت الكتائب انها
استهدفت اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه جنوب دير
البلح بقذيفتين الياسين 105 ما ادى الى
احتراقها بالكامل كما استهدفت ثلاث دبابات
صهيونيه من طراز ميركافا بقذائف الياسي
105 105 شرق خانيونس ميدانيا ايضا قالت
سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي انها قصفت حشودا للعدو في منطقه
جحر الديك بقذائف
الهول l